[MUSIC PLAYING]
- The idea for this
installation first came to me
when I was participating
in the winter
session for this competition.
And I remember being in
the Schlesinger Library
and being shown historic
maps of the Radcliffe campus
and finding myself attracted
to the buildings that
are no longer here and what
their stories might have been.
That fascination
with lost structures
was the key motivator
to incorporate them
into this public space
as part of the design.
My name is John Wang.
I was a senior in Harvard
College when I submitted
for the Radcliffe Institute
Public Art competition,
and I am now a
first year student
in the Harvard Graduate
School of Design,
studying architecture.
It was a really unbelievable
experience almost
to find out that I
won the competition
as an undergraduate.
It was a school-wide
competition,
and there were a lot
of different proposals.
It was really exciting for me
to take the idea from my mind,
to paper, to presentations,
and then finally, to reality.
Just being able to
bring an idea to life
and share it with the public is
a really incredible experience.
The plants are rosemary,
the Russian sage,
with the lavender.
A large part of the
project was predicated
on these historic footprints.
But as I was working
through design,
I realized I also wanted this to
really be a lively public space
that people would come and
have it and make it their own.
Radcliffe being a scholarly
kind of exchange environment,
this could be a place
for conversations.
Maybe people in the area would
come here and they would picnic
or they would have
lunch on the site.
And so, now that
it's here, it really
excites me to see how
people would come and use
this installation.
[MUSIC PLAYING]